as long as you put the work in and take
action then you can do it just believe
in yourself do the main things at the
start
get that sorted and everything will fall
into place
[Music]
thanks so much for coming down to my
house congratulations on your success
thank you you guys have been doing super
well we've read to rants immerse
yourself in property why don't you just
give me an intros to kind of how you
guys met and how you got started i think
it was 2018 and we went to woken
football club that's how we first met
really was playing football together
yeah and then we went to the college
working college to do the academy stuff
he was there for two years and then
danny went off to uni and then i carried
on with football
um and then as the pandemic started we
started working at amazon i was doing
night shifts and he was doing morning
shifts
and then after not speaking for a few
months we sort of came back together he
saw me in one of the shifts and then we
just started getting talking again from
there really yeah and what was it when
did you decide that you wanted to become
business partners and do property um so
we was watching a lot of your videos i
think the first thing i saw was the
financial freedom where you did it
yourself yeah and i just caught my i
think it was quite quite a high view in
video and then just kept looking at the
stuff you did and i just discussed it
really if danny i wanted to get into it
danny you're such a traditional guy
though you're such like an up the old
school mindset of get a job get educated
go to uni
and you've kind of done that alongside
property which is crazy talk to me a bit
about sort of you know why you got into
property in the first place
yeah so as joe said i met him in amazon
he watched your videos told me more
about it and then we ordered a couple
books
and then on shift we just read the books
on break time got into it booked on to
the crash course which was actually
the last crash course before covid hit
so in london there was about 200 people
in the room
we got really inspired and um
then we got networking um and yeah we
ended up getting our first rent to rent
like
a month after and you joined the
e-academy and you did a lot of the
online online courses and you sort of
started working together that first rent
to rent i actually i think i came out to
visit you at that property
do you still have that yeah oh back
again
so you've had that years now then yes
it's coming to the end now actually yeah
so that property then talk to me about
how you got that there's actually
multiple ways we've actually got each
rent to rent the first rental rate we
ended up buying um so we got for dill
saucer
so yeah we actually paid the fee without
even seeing the property so we actually
just jumped straight in we really wanted
to do it so badly which is risky it is
risky but it
the the risk was mitigated actually from
the actual do itself so we paid the food
we went up there we liked it um so we
decided to pursue it
who was the guy that you bought i'm sure
was he an academy member yeah so jamal
um
you'd obviously interview as well yeah
we saw him on here as well so he had
some credibility and we he sold the deal
to us we took it um but
the deal was actually it was 2 2 500 for
the finders fee and then it was 800
pound deposit 800 um
first month's rent yeah but we had
um 10 weeks of free rent and we tended
it within three weeks so we had
including deposits we had the money that
we spent on the deal back within the
first first payment three months and we
had a three-month break clause so after
those three months of free rent we could
have gave the place back anyway so the
risk was actually
why do you think why would jamal sell it
for two and a half grand why would he
not just do it himself
so um obviously it was a really good
deal but if he was concentrating on
other areas or didn't have the time to
do it himself right it's good to make
quick cash to offload it and also it
gives people opportunities to get into
the game as well yeah um so he was
concentrating on other stuff i think he
was doing eviction around the same time
or he's concentrating on buying places
so we just thought he'd offload the deal
to us and gave us a foot in the door i
guess not every you can't take every
opportunity that comes your way can you
exactly and if something's not in your
patch and this is the great thing about
packaging and selling deals about deal
sourcing is that
when you're out doing deals like you
guys are and you're looking at
properties and you do rent a rents and
hmos sometimes you're going to come
across stuff that doesn't work for you
but instead of just leaving it
why not package it and sell it to
another academy member or to somebody
that is is in a better location or you
know makes sense so that property then
how does it work then how's that how's
that deal structured and then we'll move
on to other deals that you've done yeah
so there's a hmo so
we pay the landlord guaranteed rent and
then we rent out room by room
um and yeah that's
800 pounds 800 pounds and then what are
you renting the rooms out for about 400
each okay so about 1600 okay so you're
making a bit of cash flow off of that
each month how much profit does that
property leave you with
about 450 500 yeah
okay
yeah so for the first deal it worked
really well as well because we got
pretty much
all the money back straight away and
then it was just a nice little profit
too and what did you learn from that
first property because i know you've
gone on to do a lot more deals your
latest deal this is a funny story
actually so
we tended it within three weeks and
the first time i went to tenant it i
finished work at amazon at like 10 30 at
night shot straight up there got there
at like 3 a.m
slept there had the viewing at nine
and it was a couple that turned up and i
didn't know at the time that i could
actually put couples in so i said no to
them and i went back home another three
hours but not knowing because i just
jumped straight in and um now obviously
i met the tenant online so i know
exactly like before i do the view and
that they're potentially going to move
in but before we didn't know that it was
just learning as well as you go along
yeah the first one was just about
experience really so there was so much
that obviously you can learn but a lot
of it is just getting down and doing it
and all that along the way yeah yes
there's times where i'd go up to do a
viewing i'd book like three within two
hour slots and then the middle one
wouldn't turn up but now i'd know to
sort of condense them down so if one
doesn't turn up i've got one half an
hour later doesn't matter how to stay
there the whole day yeah so there's a
lot of a lot of learning in that process
yeah if you space them out like if you
have a view and get one and you get two
if you get three if you get four and
then one person cancels you're waiting
around for two hours yeah you're better
off doing a block viewing or
you're having 15 minute gaps
and i think you're right though like
when you actually do it when you're
actually doing it
that's the that's just the ultimate way
to learn and of course if you're doing
it without any training whatsoever or
any mentorship or any direction then
you're probably going to get burned
you're going to make massive massively
poor
decisions but when you're doing it with
training with mentors with people around
you
then then um you know you massively grow
are you still working at amazon no
anymore no
i had enough of that place was it was it
was it good did you enjoy it it was
for anyone starting out and rent
training the best thing you can do as a
young person as well is get a job
work
six five six days a week get the money
in the bank go and get some education
learn something that's sustainable that
you want to do
and then go and do it but it was such a
good way of just
getting money in the bank learning as
well and then sort of the risk is
mitigating because you've got money
coming in
what are you doing right now
are you beating and playing football as
well part time yeah yeah so i'm quite
busy all over the place but because i do
pt and i can sort of pick my hours so if
i need to call agents or landlords or
anything i can do that during the day in
block off times yeah so that's why it's
worked well whereas you know nine to
five if you finish at five o'clock and
then agencies are shot you can't really
call them up yeah so it works quite well
with uh liaising with landlords and
agents and stuff and you're very good at
football as well right yeah yeah yeah so
it's a passion as well as getting paid
yeah yeah which which is fantastic what
are you doing for work right now so i'm
just actively finding deals at the
moment doing viewings so you're not
doing any you're not in a job already
kind you're full-time property right now
yeah and congratulations on graduating
yes thank you i'm happy with that that
has finished up the way now i was
thinking like i remember a year ago
you're like i'm gonna finish my
my uni and i was like i don't understand
why man like what's the point of
studying and getting a degree if you
know you're never going to need a job
yeah but in your mind you sound exactly
but you spent a year bro i know what's
the rationale behind that why did you
want to finish studying in unison
because you've now graduated well i went
to uni
because i didn't really know what i
wanted to do it was more like socially
accepted time wasting
but at the same time i didn't really let
uni limit me i know people go to union
and they feel like they're stuck all
they can do is
go to the library learn get your degree
and party but that's not really what
we've done lockdown happened went into
full time working started the business
doing
education alongside of it so it didn't
really limit me but as soon as i started
the property journey i thought right
i'm already too far in to stop uni but i
know now i just need to get it over and
done with and then i can crack on yeah
yeah which you've done so
congratulations what do you think about
the because i know you weren't too sure
about him doing you know i think i think
we both know now that if he could go
back to the beginning it probably
wouldn't be the best idea
but i think
at the same time the fact that he's done
it he finished a degree yeah he's done a
marathon as well he's
yeah he's done the business stuff and
worked full-time so i think that it's
good that he knows that he can do all of
that and he has a capability to juggle
things yeah so i think that's another
thing that you've got to remember is
that even though he's doing full-time
studying he's also studying property
doing it as well
it just comes down to
what you want just prioritize i think
you should always take on more than you
actually think you can do as well
because a lot of times
like when you're back's against the wall
you're sort of forced to do it so like
one example was i was like three days
from doing my dissertation and one of
the tenants and sheffield snapped the
door handle so they couldn't get in and
they were locked out and this was like
four in the morning and i've got i've
got like the biggest
thing going on with uni right now but i
managed to go up there change the door
handle luckily i found a guy in um
toolbox and he had the he had there was
a guy in the queue he had a metal piece
for the door handle but i couldn't find
it anywhere i went everywhere during the
day to get it but didn't have it but
yeah i guess luck was on my side fixed
the door and then went and finished my
degree but it's just once your backs
against the wall you've got so many
things going on you're forced to succeed
in a way because you've got no other
choice
i guess everyone's different you are
correct that when you've got pressure on
yourself
elon musk said if you give yourself six
months to tidy your bedroom it will take
six months so you kind of put yourself
you had you were juggling with your uni
your education also your property
education on on the academy
also actually doing the business but i
guess if that's how you like to work if
you were just full-time in property
maybe you'd just been twiddling your
thumbs and you know
not not going hard what's um what was
your second deal then what was the
second deal it was another rent event
right this was this was a good one so
this second one wasn't we found this
ourselves um director landlord this time
and this was during lockdown as well and
the landlord actually couldn't tenant
the place because
uni students were going home and we were
struggling to put it in so we we when
viewed it put in an offer
paid no no deposit just straight rent um
and yeah we agreed a couple of weeks as
well before to get the property ready
before we'd actually pay our first
month's rent so we negotiated no deposit
and then like three weeks where we could
jazz everything up get all the bedding
and stuff and then pay our first month's
rent wow we're able to book in viewings
take photos and get people in before we
really have to pay out how did you get
around the the referencing issues
because you guys like when you started
when you got your first retweet you're
above teenagers yeah
which is crazy man you know you're both
teenagers how did you get through and
you're working at amazon and studying so
being able to say to a landlord i can
guarantee the rent and it's like really
how can you guarantee the rent so how
did you get around that
yeah so we had
the second sheffield property that we
found was actually on the same road as
the one we had
and we obviously had that already
tenanted so we could say
we can help you here we've already got
nurses
because this is right opposite of the
hospital this these hmos we've already
got nurses in this property we're
already doing it we can show you can
give you references from the land that
we currently are doing the property with
we said that to him and he was happy to
oblige yeah
yeah he didn't actually ask us for any
like proper references which was lucky
but the one that we've just done we use
our parents didn't we it's like because
you have to clarify certain amount of
income you actually have to use our
parents for that one but it's always
around ways around stuff like that
there's always a way yeah always but you
know what though there's some people out
there that are very like broke-minded
people i don't say broke people i say
broken-minded because your your bank
balance will always follow your brain
and
they'll always find a reason as to why
something can't work so they'll go like
oh how do you get around this though
what about this what about that you just
said you secured your second property
with no deposit
no upfront rent
so what did you pay to the landlord up
front so there's nothing there's a no
money down deal yeah so you paid nothing
upfront no references no
and what was the monthly profit on that
when you you know once you got that full
so that was decent wasn't it yeah yeah
five five fifty about five five fifteen
months profit how long did it take to
fill it
uh that was like a month as well wasn't
it yeah but we'd already obviously we
got money in the bank before we'd had to
pay out
so we already had enough even if we
didn't have any money in a bank
we'd secured enough money that we'd be
able to pay the first month's rent
before obviously paying it
and at this point
as teenagers
like it's pretty it's pretty incredible
really and then this the reason we
didn't pay any deposit is because all we
said was
the tenants are going to pay their
deposit to us so we hold their deposit
therefore you don't need a deposit
because if anything went wrong we would
use their deposit brilliant yeah that's
so and that's so genius because the
landlord of course the landlord's going
to want to deposit because something
might break so we might go wrong so
you're going to say to the landlord um
and of course this is what we teach on
on the academy you can say to the
landlord hey obviously there needs to be
a deposit in case something breaks we
need to make sure the property's in good
condition
we'll be taking care of all the deposits
so when the tenants move in we'll be
holding them we'll be registering them
which means you don't have to worry
about anything because they're okay yeah
and then suddenly bang you've got no
deposit to have to pay and then in terms
of the rent genius what you guys did
which is just a case of locating
attackers a few weeks to get the things
ready um we'll start the contract from
the first of next month um but would it
be okay if we get the keys today so we
can start staging it because we want to
improve the property we want to furnish
it we want to make it really attractive
the landlord's thinking well if i moved
into 10 normal tenant in they'd usually
have to give me a month's notice anyway
right so it's no different for the
landlord but from your perspective bang
you can start marketing the property
straight away so that come the first of
next month you've got full tenants ready
to roll which is just absolutely
fantastic
where did the drive come from like you
know the fact that you were studying
full-time you're doing football ptn like
to be able to bolt this on and get no
money down rent to rent i mean how did
you even afford like the academy for
instance like that's obviously thousands
of pounds you both invested heavily into
the training
where did that drive come from and how
did you manage to get through that those
barriers of it to entry i don't think
the drive was
there at the beginning it was just
lockdown happen i don't want to sit at
home i'll get a job
and then suddenly this money's coming in
and then
i'm like 19 and i was like crikey i've
got like 10 grand now like just
accumulated i didn't even look at my
account really just money coming in and
i'm like right i could actually do
something here yeah then we
then we obviously done the trade um done
the read the books watch the videos we
thought okay now we can actually afford
to do some training that's how we're
going to learn yeah i think yeah we're
we're people where if if we want to do
something we'll go 100 at it
and i think we're both quite like-minded
in that sense so as soon as we saw the
videos we're inspired pretty much
straight away and we could see ourselves
in a year's time being that person
that's why we said when we did our first
deal
looking at our first education was like
we're going to go on winners on a
wednesday we're going to get there one
day
yeah i think people think like success
is so far away
but if you start it's the ball starts to
roll and things start to happen
you need to get started and then stuff
starts to unfold yeah especially when
you're younger you think oh that's for
older people and i'm not going to get
there yet but hopefully we're examples
that you can start early yeah and as
long as you put the work in you're no
different to someone that's 30 40 that
has the credibility yes you can carry
yourself well negotiate and then get
educated properly then anyone can do it
um how did you justify the investment
into the training because that's like a
lot of
long savings and hard work you're
teenagers how did you justify that
decision well you have to think a lot of
people go to uni and spend
four or five times the amount
on a job that's going to be working for
someone else and it's not a guarantee at
the end of it also there's nothing wrong
with it but you're spending out all of
that money and there's no guarantee at
the end that you're going to be earning
a certain amount whereas like your
training for example
you know it's it's it's a lot less than
if you go to university and the
prospects are a lot bigger i'd say
um so it's just a case of what your
priorities are and you're buying less of
a bullet than if you were to spend a lot
more into a university degree yeah plus
i'm
19. if i've got this money i'm gonna go
to the shop i'm gonna buy some clothes a
nice pair of trainers
and then that'll be it or i can actually
use the money properly get an education
learn how to do something that makes a
lot of money make even more so i don't
know why it doesn't make sense why
people don't do it because they're just
going to waste the money anyway you
might as well spend on something
valuable that's going to increase your
like increase your knowledge so yeah
it's a win-win i guess everyone's just
different and and for me like when
people
pay thousands of pounds for my trainers
who are teenagers like for me it's a bit
of responsibility because it makes me
think like man
you know if this doesn't work if this
doesn't work out and i know i was on
your case quite a lot especially the
first few months like how's it going
what's happening because it's like you
know i just i just think massive respect
but myself as well when i started that i
was 17 years old i spent thousands of
pounds going on property courses at the
time people laughed at me and i'm
thinking well you're going to uni
well
it didn't make any sense to me but i
think it's almost just against the grain
isn't it you know the status quo would
say oh well you're not going to get a
degree at the end of the training and
it's like yeah but i'm not doing it to
get a degree i'm doing it because i want
to be able to actually become
financially free
um
what's um talk to me about your latest
deal
yeah so it's in brighton um
where did you get this one uh january
this year okay so yeah so yeah so
obviously danny was at union nottingham
yeah and we knew that he was moving down
south in the summer when he finished his
degree um so that's why we sort of
looked at brighton in terms of sa
and then at the start of the year we was
like right we're going to get an essay
in brighton
and then it took about two or three
weeks of just continuous phone calls to
agents um and we find it's recorded
essay in brighton
um it was through an agency what do you
say essay sorry whatever accommodation
so that's a property that you're gonna
rent out on short stay let's yeah
okay yeah so it's a nightly basis
um obviously it's it's right in the
center of brighton next to the beach so
we can charge premiums every night um
and then we get cleaners in in between
the stays so we pay rent to the landlord
per month and then we charge per night
on the booking.com airbnb and obviously
the in-between premium is profit fast
yeah
yeah so you're paying how much you
paying to the landlord
yeah 12.50 12.50 so that's quite a
sizable amount of money to be
typically committed to paying and how
long is the contract over three years
three years so you've got a minimum
three year contract you're paying 1250 a
month
you started the contract january so that
now it's august so
about actually about eight months
is it making money what's going on yeah
this is
this one really fell into yeah this one
makes triple the amount
of both the how much you're making on it
between sort of 1500 to like 1900 yeah
around that
yeah this one especially summer now it's
about peak season
it's like 97 occupancy this month
yeah we're charging like 200 a night at
the moment and it's all the way through
because it's a hot month july or august
nearly four and a half years what about
in the early part of the year though
like you got this in january how did it
go the first like how was it in january
yeah it was tougher in january nightly
stays were less yeah we still had high
it was strange we still had high
occupancy but it's just a nightly rate
to ls but we're still able to cover rent
and bills and make a little bit on top
yeah so it wasn't at a loss but it's
just there's a big difference between
seasonality in terms of how much you can
charge in peak of summer yeah and then
winter times and now we've got some
reviews and got some credit yeah so the
fact that the fact that you made profit
in your first month which was january
with zero reviews and you still might
and you still made profit on it i mean
that's it
on the seaside in january and that was
it so we got the keys a week early and
we had a week to it was it came empty so
we had a week to fully like refurb the
place get everything in got it in
put it on was it like the third of
january we listed it yeah and then yeah
straight away yeah how booked up are you
now are you booked up for september yeah
we're both sure yeah but we only i don't
know why but we only leave
two months
open in advance we haven't left it for
the whole
year yeah yeah
why'd you do that so basically we'll
leave
two months and then we'll cut it off so
you can't pass there because a lot of
people will put last minute so they'll
go on booking.com and they'll see yeah
they'll have a council or they'll see
that oh there's not many left so i'm
gonna have to pay the premium of this
one so if you leave it open early
then people will book straight away but
you can charge more rates than later on
which is kind of a risk but if you leave
a few days of a month yeah yeah yeah so
it's all part of like the strategy of
how can we get the most bookings for the
maximum pay yeah so so so
you literally make it how much do you
say per month on average that that one
property max 1500 on average 1500
dollars we made i think it's about 2k
wasn't it yeah and how much were you
making when you were at amazon about two
grand
yeah yeah that was six days a week
that was six days a week overtime pay
there was a two pound uh surplus because
of kovid yeah that was just
non-stop yeah it's just that yeah
average weight is like 10 12 pounds an
hour so the fact that you replaced
a wage
with one deal is just ridiculous isn't
it yeah yeah that's that's the thing we
we really underestimated essays but
they're so lucrative especially in like
the height of differences yeah why do
you think it took you so long because
i've obviously had the service
accommodation training right at the
beginning and i know sometimes you know
it it's normal you can't when you go on
all the training programs you can't do
everything at once and you kind of
mastered rent to rent mastered hmo
you know now you're killing service
accommodation but why do you think it
took you so long even when you have the
training um
it's a good question i just think
because
we thought the beginning essay would be
a bit more hard to manage with
everything going on having people in and
out all the time it's just hmo get
people in for six months you don't
really have to attend to anything after
that um see that's the reason really i
think we got it the wrong way around
yeah we thought our hmos would be easier
we'll get our foot in the door and then
we'll go into essays because it's more
complex but you can systemize yeah
essays so well and the income is so much
better for 90 days because you can
charge a premium because it's per night
rather than per month
so it's like people like yourself as
well even though you can still do these
big
big money deals and buy houses etcetera
but you still choose to do essays
because the cash flow is so great yeah
and cash flows is coming in helps all
the time so and also with service
accommodation you're not dealing with
tenants you're dealing with guests so
there's no fear of them not paying rent
and having to evict them because they
haven't got any rights if they don't pay
the rent then they just have to go
immediately
but i think every every strategy has its
pros and cons and it's really important
to have like a toolbox and to understand
how to do everything so that you can
become a property problem solver speak
to landlords and just say how can i help
some properties are more suited to hmos
some will be more suited to service
accommodation but you guys are doing
both thing and killing it how hard was
it getting
like what would you say
the best tips are when you're trying to
get a rent to rent like what to say to
the agents or the landlords
yeah um so
is a funny story so the first time we
ever made a phone call
um where were we were in starbucks
upstairs in starbucks and um you call uh
joe called the person was in like
scotland just practicing and was like i
was like hi i've seen this property um
could you tell me a bit more about it
and then the guy was like yeah what
would you like to know and joe was like
uh
hung up and they were like i was like no
i'm not having that so like two minutes
later
rang it back up i said sorry dodgy
connection and then yeah it was just
like hi i've seen a property um on one
two three norfolk road as well if you
tell me more about is that what you want
to know
yeah that was that was the first ever
photo wasn't it how many bathrooms does
it have whatever i'm really interested
in i would love to come and view it it's
like yeah that's fine book of you and i
said yeah it wouldn't be for myself
personally but it'll be for my company
but i'm able to book it on this day
monday works for me yes
and it's really it's literally it's just
trial and error and then
and then make 100 phone calls
you get 10 viewings that's what we never
brian we made 100 phone calls 10
viewings um put seven offers and got one
yeah yeah it's just just keep just keep
going if you get a rejection that is the
game the game is actually a lot of
projection yeah and you're not going to
work on a first phone call that's what i
learned yeah like the first one i
completely messed up dude i remember my
first i remember my first i went into an
agency and i walked in and i had my
script ready and my mouth dried up
because i was so nervous and i couldn't
speak i was just they were like oh how
can we help and i was like
completely you know but the thing is
unless you're prepared
to actually do it yeah you know
it's never going to happen you're going
to get better and better you had
obviously a great script
you know but like
you've got to just do it haven't you
yeah you've got it yeah yeah you've got
to accept that your first few aren't
going to be great yeah um but it's about
learning what works and what doesn't so
at first um when i was calling up agents
i was saying
straight away i want to do a company let
and i've straight away just turn off the
yeah there is and then obviously from
real training i learned that you sort of
you don't hide it but you'll say ah so
uh would be under a company let when's
the best day to view it yeah um and it's
just learning what works really and then
your success rate will increase in terms
of the amount of bookings and viewings
you will get exactly and if you're
saying the wrong thing if you don't know
what you're doing and you're doing
viewings and you don't know what you're
talking about you're just winging it
you're going to fail 100 of the time
yeah if you say the right thing and
you've got it script perfect you're
still probably going to fail 70 of the
time but then it's a numbers game so
it's about knowing what to say doing the
right thing but also consistently doing
it and i think as well it's so important
in my opinion to do it like you you guys
were working together i think if you're
on your own and you're isolated and
you're just at home in your bedroom
ringing people
after three rejections you're gonna quit
whereas if you're in if you're if you
can find partners business partners
accountability buddies success buddies
be in a community be an environment and
you're working together and you're
making calls
then it's so much easier you know
ringing in scotland
as practice
genius because that way you're thinking
i'm never going to see them ever again
it doesn't matter what happens
when we went to the event the i would
never have made a phone call at the um
like normally at home we went to the
events you're in the environment yeah
and you're like forced to do it you meet
up with some random person you're like
right here here's five minutes make a
phone call you have to make a phone call
like you're on the spot you just have to
do it and it gets you out your shell
yeah and you grow your confidence so
much and that's such a big thing because
property is such a people's
um
like industry so yeah learning like
going to these events talking to people
getting the confidence it helps so much
another question is danny now you've
graduated we were over the moon when you
graduated me and you're like right now
no distractions and and you've just
revealed that you you signed up for
another year
to get your quantity surveying master's
degree yeah which is awesome but i'm
just trying to get the rationale behind
why yeah because you're never going to
need a job and you know that yeah
to be honest properties
now i know what i want to do before i
didn't know what i want to do i knew i
was good at sports i thought i'd go
study a sports degree
now i know i want to do property
quantity experience in construction and
real estate and that's just something
i'm really interested in um it gives me
good credibility i learn a lot about
sort of developments etc so for it's two
day a week degree i can still do my
property on five days a week regardless
so i thought no-brainers are just going
carry on education that makes sense so
how long it's two days a week
for how long a year
one year
and that's in quantity surveying but
you've not done any training in quantity
seven already no
so how are you gonna get a master's in
one year two days a week so um
with a masters not every degree
necessarily needed to have studied
um that subject previously um you just
needed a certain grade to get in
which i got and
also you have to say sort of why you
want to do it and have maybe have some
experience in it which i kind of did
doing this property as well that's why
in my personal statement i mentioned
what i've been doing and mentioned your
name as well and said um yeah i've done
some of these training as well i've
learned all about this brrs construction
contracts etc um and then obviously
they were happy with my personal
statement to accept me amazing amazing
so one year
and then you'll be a master's degree in
quantity surveying that's great what's
your goals for the future then like
what's the vision now moving forward
you've you've you've achieved a lot so
far a young age what's the what's the
what's next so we want to continue in
brighton getting essays
and we want to be comfortable in
replacing our income so we can do that
full-time
and then go into purchasing and doing
brrs and stuff like that yeah right it's
definitely yeah forward yeah from there
yeah
and how old are you guys now i know when
you started i think you were 18 and 19.
what you know 21 22 21 yeah
nice amazing and what will be your final
words of advice for somebody maybe who's
even you know a teenager maybe they're
19 or just starting out in property for
brand new what would your best advice be
in the first steps getting started what
would you say
i would say
if i could go back what i'd want someone
say to me is
you can do it and
when you're 16 17 18 you think that the
goals that people are reaching are so
far out of touch in your reality
but it's definitely not so achievable
you can be a regular person from a
regular background any background at all
but as long as you put the work in and
take action then you can do it just
believe in yourself and you can 100 get
there i used to be the guy that thought
oh maybe i'll do it maybe i won't but i
just stuck to the action
and did the right education got
knowledge on what i was supposed to be
doing and then got there in some
something so yeah literally what we done
is
we got a job earn a little bit of money
went and done some education learned
about property and went and done it but
i think the best thing i can say is
a lot of times
you'd worry about the xyz and you would
never start the abcs so just do the main
things at the start get that sorted and
everything will fall into place but
don't think about oh the tap might break
i'm never going to call an agent up
because you haven't even even booked a
viewing yet and you're already thinking
about yeah ever so just focus on what
needs to get done get the training make
the phone calls put the viewings and
then worry about everything like later
on well guys congratulations on your
success thanks for coming on and sharing
because i think you're going to inspire
a lot of people and uh we're going to
watch your space and see you guys
continue to blow yes thank you awesome
modern respect
[Music]